the mathematics we learn in school
doesn't quite do the field of
mathematics justice we only get a
glimpse at one corner of it but
mathematics as a whole is a huge and
wonderfully diverse subject my aim with
this video is to show you all of that
amazing stuff we'll start back at the
very beginning the origin of mathematics
lies in accounting in fact counting is
not just a human trait other animals are
able to count as well an evidence for
human counting goes back to prehistoric
times with check marks made in bones
there were several innovations over the
years with the Egyptians having the
first equation the ancient Greeks making
strides in many areas like geometry and
numerology negative numbers were
invented in China zero as a number was
first used in India then in the Golden
Age of Islam Persian mathematicians made
further strides and the first book on
algebra was written then mathematics
boomed in the Renaissance along with the
sciences now there's a lot more to the
history of mathematics than what I've
just said but I'm going to jump to the
modern age and mathematics as we know it
now modern mathematics can broadly be
broken down into two areas
pure Maps the study of mathematics for
its own sake and applied maps when you
develop mathematics to help solve some
real-world problem but there's a lot of
crossover in fact many times in history
someone's gone off into the mathematical
wilderness motivated purely by curiosity
and kind of guided by a sense of
aesthetics and then they've created a
whole bunch of new mathematics which is
nice and interesting but it doesn't
really do anything useful but then say a
hundred years later someone will be
working on some problem at the cutting
edge of physics or computer science and
they'll discover that this old theory in
pure math is exactly what they need to
solve their real-world problems
which is amazing I think and this kind
of thing has happened so many times over
the last few centuries it's interesting
how often something so abstract ends up
being really useful but I should also
mention that pure mathematics on its own
is still a very valuable thing to do
because it can be fascinating and on its
own can have a real beauty and elegance
that almost becomes like art okay enough
of this highfalutin let's get into it
pure Maps is made of several sections
the study of numbers starts with the
natural numbers and what you can do with
them with arithmetic operations and then
it looks at other kinds of numbers like
integers which contain negative numbers
rational numbers like fractions real
numbers which include numbers like pi
which go off to infinite decimal points
and then complex numbers and a whole
bunch of others some numbers have
interesting properties like prime
numbers or pi or the exponential there
are also properties of these number
systems for example even though there's
an infinite amount with both integers
and real numbers there are more real
numbers than integers so some infinities
are bigger than others
the study of structures is where you
start taking numbers and putting them
into equations in the form of variables
algebra contains the rules of how you
then manipulate these equations here
you'll also find vectors and matrices
which are multidimensional numbers and
the rules of how they relate to each
other are captured in linear algebra
number theory studies the features of
everything in the last section on
numbers like the properties of prime
numbers combinatorics looks at the
properties of certain structures like
trees graphs and other things that are
made a discrete chunk that you can count
group Theory looks at objects that are
related to each other in wealth groups a
familiar example is a rubik's cube which
is an example of a permutation group and
order Theory investigates how to arrange
objects following certain rules like how
something is a larger quantity than
something else the natural numbers are
in the example of an ordered set of
objects but anything with any two-way
relationship can be ordered another part
of pure mathematics looks at shapes and
how they behave in spaces the origin is
in geometry which includes Pythagoras
and is close to trigonometry which I'm
sure we're all familiar with from school
also there are fun things like fractal
geometry which are mathematical patterns
which are scale invariant which means
you can zoom into them forever and they
always look kind of the same topology
looks at different properties of spaces
where you're allowed to continuously
deform them but not tear or glue them
for example a mobius strip there's only
one surface in one edge whatever you do
to it and coffee cups and donuts are the
same thing topologically speaking major
theory is a way to assign values to
spaces or sets tying together numbers
and spaces and finally differential
geometry looks at the properties of
shapes on curved surfaces for example
triangles have got different angles on a
curved surface and brings us to the next
section which is changes the study of
changes contains calculus which involves
integrals and differentials which look
so the area spanned out by functions or
the behavior of gradients of functions
in vector calculus looks at the same
thing but for vectors here we also find
a bunch of other areas like dynamical
systems which looks at systems that
evolve in time from one state to another
like fluid flows or things with feedback
groups like ecosystems and chaos theory
which studies dynamical systems that are
very sensitive to initial conditions
finally complex analysis looks at the
properties of functions with complex
numbers this brings us to applied
mathematics at this point is probably
worth mentioning that everything here is
a lot more interrelated than I've drawn
in reality this map should look more
like a web tying together all the
different subjects but you can only do
so much on a two-dimensional plane so
I've laid them out as best I can
okay we'll start with physics which uses
just about everything on the left-hand
side to some degree mathematical and
theoretical physics is a very close
relationship with pure maths mathematics
is also used in the other Natural
Sciences with mathematical chemistry and
biomathematics which look at loads of
stuff from modeling molecules to
evolutionary biology mathematics is also
used extensively in engineering building
things has taken a lot of maths since
the Egyptians and Babylonians very
complex electrical systems like
aeroplanes or the power grid use methods
in dynamical systems caused control
theory numerical analysis is a
mathematical tool commonly used in
places where mathematics becomes too
complex to solve completely so instead
you use lots of simple approximations
and combine them all together to get a
good approximate answers for example if
you put a circle inside a square
throw darts at it and then compare the
number of darts in the circle and the
square portions you can approximate the
value of pi but in the real world
numerical analysis is done on huge
computers game theory looks at what the
best choices are given a set of rules
and rational players and it's used in
economics when the players can be
intelligent but not always and
other areas like psychology and biology
probability is the study of random
events like coin tosses or dice or
humans and statistics is the study of
large collections of random processes or
the organization and analysis of data
this is obviously related to
mathematical finance where you want to a
model financial system and get an edge
to win all those fat stacks related to
this is optimization where you're trying
to calculate the best choice amongst a
set of many different options or
constraints which you normally visualize
is trying to find the highest or lowest
point of a function optimization
problems the second nature to us humans
and we do them all the time trying to
get the best value for money or trying
to maximize our happiness in some way
another area that's very deeply related
to pure mathematics is computer science
and the rules of computer science were
actually derived in pure math and is
another example of something that was
worked there way before programmable
computers were built machine learning
the creation of intelligent computer
systems uses many areas in mathematics
like linear algebra optimization
dynamical systems and probability and
finally the theory of cryptography is
very important computation and uses a
lot of pure maps like combinatorics and
number theory so that covers the main
sections of pure and applied mathematics
but I can't end without looking at the
foundations of mathematics his area
tries to work out the properties of
mathematics itself and asks what the
basis of all the rules of mathematics is
is there a complete set of fundamental
rules called axioms which all of
mathematics comes from and can we prove
that it's all consistent with itself
mathematical logic set theory in
category theory try to answer this and a
famous result in mathematical logic our
girdle's incompleteness theorems which
for most people means that mathematics
does not have a complete and consistent
set of axioms which means that it's all
kind of made up by us humans which is
weird seeing as mathematics explains so
much stuff in the universe so well why
would a thing made up by humans be able
to do that that is a deep mystery
right there we also have the theory of
computation which looks at different
models of computing and how efficiently
they can solve problems and contains
complexity theory which looks at what is
and isn't computable and how much memory
in time you would need which for most
interesting problems is an insane amount
so that is the map of mathematics now
the thing I've loved most about learning
maps is that feeling you get where
something that seems so confusing
finally clicks in your brain and
everything makes sense like an epiphany
moment kind of like seeing through the
matrix in fact some of my most
satisfying intellectual moments have
been understanding some part of
mathematics and then feeling like I had
a glimpse at the fundamental nature of
the universe in all of its symmetrical
wonder it's great I love it
making a map of mathematics was the most
popular request I got I was really happy
about it because I loved math and it was
great to see so much interest in it so I
hope you enjoyed it
what we see there's only so much I can
get into this time frame but I hopefully
I've done the subject justice and you've
found it useful
so there'll be more videos coming from
me soon here's all the regular things
and it was my pleasure
see you next time